mais que plus vous êtes proche du blanc sur ce spectre,
mieux vous vous portez.
Et plus vous êtes proche du noir sur ce spectre,
le moins bien vous vous portez.
Quand nous pensons à comment nous gérons les problèmes dans ce pays,
nous commençons souvent par une justice de retombées.
En utilisant les personnes blanches comme un contrôle,
si nous améliorons les choses pour elles,
tout le monde va être libéré.
Mais cela ne fonctionne pas ainsi.
Nous devons gérer les problèmes à l'origine
et quand vous gérez ce qu'il se passe dans les communautés noires,
cela crée de l'effervescence, n'est-ce pas ?
Une approche de remontées plutôt que de retombées.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
En parlant de l'écart de salaire,
nous disons souvent que les femmes gagnent 78 centimes
pour chaque dollar qu'un homme gagne.
Vous avez tous déjà entendu cela.
Mais ce sont des statistiques pour des femmes et des hommes blancs.
En réalité, les femmes noires gagnent 64 centimes
pour les 78 centimes qu'une femme blanche gagne.
Si on parle de latinas, on tombe à 58 centimes.
Et si on parlait des femmes indigènes,
si on parlait des femmes transgenres,
cela tomberait encore plus bas.
A nouveau,
en gérant ce qu'il se passe pour les plus affectés,
tout le monde a l'opportunité d'en bénéficier,
plutôt que de gérer ce qu'il se passe pour les personnes blanches non affectées
et s'attendre à des retombées.
MB : J'adore l'effervescence,
les remontées.
AG : L'effervescence, comme du champagne.
(Rires)
MB : Qui n'aime pas un verre de champagne ?
Du champagne et de la liberté ?
(Rires)
Que demander de plus ?
Vous faites cela depuis une minute
et les dernières années ont été --
je ne peux pas l'imaginer
mais, j'en suis sûre, transformatrices.
Je sais que vous en avez toutes beaucoup appris sur le leadership.
Que voulez-vous partager quant à ce que vous avez appris du leadership ?
Patrisse, commençons avec vous.
PC : Nous devons investir dans le leadership noir.
C'est ce que j'ai appris les dernières années.
(Applaudissements)
Nous avons vu des milliers de personnes noires se battre pour nos vies
en ayant peu d'infrastructures et très peu de soutien.
Notre travail de meneuses du mouvement ne relève pas que de notre visibilité
mais plutôt de comment rendre tout le mouvement visible.
Comment ne pas seulement se battre pour nous, individus,
mais se battre pour tout le monde ?
Je pense aussi
que le leadership permettrait de voir tout le public
se manifester pour les vies des noirs.
Il ne s'agit pas juste de venir voir des gens sur scène, n'est-ce pas ?
Il s'agit de comment devenir ce dirigeant --
que ce soit au travail ou à la maison --
et croire que le mouvement pour les vies des noirs
n'est pas que pour nous mais qu'il est pour tout le monde.
(Applaudissements)
MB : Et vous, Opal ?
OT : J'en ai beaucoup appris sur l'interdépendance.
J'ai appris à faire confiance à mon équipe.
J'ai trouvé ce nouveau mantra
après être revenue de trois mois de congés sabbatiques,
ce qui arrive rarement à une femme noire qui est dans le leadership,
mais je pensais qu'il était important pour mon leadership et mon équipe
de pratiquer la prise de recul
ainsi que, parfois, l'implication.
Ce que j'ai appris au passage est que nous devons reconnaître
que différentes personnes apportent différentes forces
et que, pour que notre équipe prospère,
nous devons leur permettre de partager et briller.
Durant mon congé sabbatique,
avec l'organisation avec laquelle je travaille aussi,
j'ai vu notre équipe progresser pendant mon absence.
Ils ont pu lancer de nouveaux programmes,
lever des fonds.
Quand je suis revenue,
j'ai été très reconnaissante et les ai félicités
car ils m'ont montré que je pouvais compter sur eux
et qu'ils pouvaient compter sur eux-mêmes.
Durant mon congé sabbatique,
on m'a vraiment rappelée
cette philosophie ubuntu d'Afrique du Sud.
Je suis car vous êtes ;
vous êtes car je suis.
J'ai réalisé que mon leadership
et les contributions que je pouvais faire
sont en grande partie dus aux contributions qu'ils font.
J'ai reconnu cela et je dois le voir,
mon nouveau mantra est donc :
« Reste calme, fais confiance à l'équipe. »
Et aussi :
« Reste calme, remercie l'équipe. »
MB : Une des choses que j'ai entendues
dans le contexte du mouvement Black Lives Matter plus qu'ailleurs,
c'est d'être un mouvement plein de leadership
et c'est un concept magnifique.
Je pense qu'une chose
que les femmes apportent dans la conversation sur le leadership,
c'est l’œuvre collective.
Et vous, Alicia ?
AG : Ouais...
Combien d'entre vous ont entendu dire que le leadership est solitaire ?
Je pense qu'il y a un élément où le leadership est solitaire
mais je crois aussi que ça n'a pas à être ainsi.
Et pour que nous en arrivions là,
je pense que nous devrions faire plusieurs choses.
Nous devons arrêter de traiter les dirigeants comme des super-héros.
Nous sommes des gens ordinaires essayant de faire des choses extraordinaires
et il nous faut du soutien.
L'autre chose que j'ai apprise sur le leadership
est qu'il y a une différence entre le leadership et les célébrités.
D'une certaine façon, nous avons été transformées en célébrités
plutôt qu'en personnes essayant de résoudre un problème.
Nous traitons les célébrités d'une façon très volatile.
Un jour nous les aimons,
le lendemain nous n'aimons pas ce qu'elles portent
et, soudain, nous avons des problèmes.
Nous devons arrêter de déifier les dirigeants
afin que plus de personnes s'engagent dans le leadership.
Beaucoup sont terrifiés de s'engager dans le leadership
à cause de la surveillance et de la brutalité envers les dirigeants.
La dernière chose que j'ai apprise sur le leadership
est qu'il est très simple d'être un dirigeant quand on vous aime.
Mais il est difficile d'être un dirigeant quand il faut faire des choix difficiles
et qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut,
même lorsque les gens ne vous aimeront pas à cause de cela.
De ce fait,
une autre façon de soutenir les dirigeants
est de lutter avec nous,
mais lutter politiquement
et non personnellement.
Nous pouvons avoir des désaccords sans être désagréables
mais il est important que nous nous affinions les uns les autres,
pour que nous nous améliorions.
MB : C'est beau, merci.
(Applaudissements)
Vous faites toutes un travail
qui vous oblige à faire face à des réalités brutales, douloureuses
au quotidien.
Qu'est-ce qui vous donne de l'espoir et vous inspire dans ce contexte ?
PC : J'ai de l'espoir en le futur des personnes noires.
Je dis cela car nous vivons dans une société
qui est tant obsédée par la mort des personnes noires.
Il y a des images de notre mort sur l'écran de la télévision,
dans nos fils d'actualités Twitter,
dans nos fils d'actualités Facebook
mais et si, à la place, nous imaginions la vie des personnes noires ?
Nous imaginons les personnes noires qui vivent et réussissent.
Et cela m'inspire.
OT : Ce qui m'inspire ces jours-ci, ce sont les immigrants.
Les immigrants à travers le monde qui font de leur mieux
pour gagner de quoi vivre, survivre et réussir.
Actuellement, il y a plus de 244 millions de personnes
qui ne vivent pas dans leur pays d'origine.
C'est une augmentation de 40% depuis l'année 2000.
Cela me dit
que les inégalités à travers le monde ne font qu'empirer.
Pourtant, il y a des gens qui trouvent la force et les moyens de voyager,
de déménager,
de péniblement gagner de quoi mieux vivre
et de subvenir aux besoins de leur famille et êtres chers.
Certaines de ces personnes qui sont immigrantes
sont aussi sans papiers.
Elles n'ont pas d'autorisation.
Et elles m'inspirent encore plus
car, bien que notre société leur dise ne pas vouloir d'eux,
ne pas avoir besoin d'eux,
bien qu'ils soient très vulnérables, sujets aux abus, au vol salarial,
à l'exploitation et aux attaques xénophobes,
nombre d'entre eux commencent à s'organiser en communautés.
Ce que je vois, c'est un réseau émergent
de personnes noires, sans papiers, qui résistent à la structure
et à la criminalisation de leur existence.
Et, pour moi, cela est incroyablement puissant
et cela m'inspire au quotidien.
MB : Merci.
Alicia ?
AG : Nous savons que les jeunes sont le présent et le futur
mais ce qui m'inspire, ce sont les personnes âgées
qui se transforment au service de ce mouvement.
Nous savons qu'en vieillissant,
vous vous retranchez dans vos opinions.
Cela m'arrive, je sais que c'est vrai.
Mais cela m'inspire de voir des gens qui ont une manière de faire les choses,
une manière de voir le monde
et qui ont le courage de s'ouvrir, d'écouter les expériences
de beaucoup d'entre nous voulant vivre dans un monde juste
et dans un monde équitable.
Et je suis aussi inspirée par les actions des personnes âgées
au service de ce mouvement.
Cela m'inspire de voir des personnes âgées s'engager dans le pouvoir et le leadership
et dire : « Je ne fais pas que passer le témoin,
je vous aide à avancer. »
(Applaudissements)
MB : J'aime cela --
oui.
En termes d'action,
je pense que c'est génial d'être ici et de pouvoir vous écouter,
que nos esprits soient ouverts et changent
mais cela ne va pas libérer les personnes noires.
S'il y a une chose que vous aimeriez que ce public
et les gens qui regardent partout dans le monde fassent,
qu'est-ce que ce serait ?
AG : Deux choses rapides.
Un : appeler la Maison Blanche.
Les protecteurs de l'eau sont déplacés de force
du camp qu'ils ont établi pour protéger ce qui nous tient en vie.
Cela est étroitement lié aux vies des personnes noires.
Donc appelez la Maison Blanche et exigez qu'ils arrêtent cela.
Il y a des tanks
et des officiers de police qui arrêtent tout le monde en ce moment même.
(Applaudissements)
La deuxième chose que vous pouvez faire
est de rejoindre quelque chose.
Faire partie d'une chose.
Il y a des groupes, des collectifs --
cela n'a pas à être une organisation à but non lucratif.
Mais il y a des groupes qui travaillent actuellement dans nos communautés
pour que les vies des personnes noires comptent
afin que toutes les vies comptent.
Impliquez-vous,
ne restez pas assis sur le canapé à dire aux gens quoi faire.
Venez le faire avec nous.
MB : Voulez-vous ajouter quelque chose ?
C'est bon ? Très bien.
Je pense que rejoindre quelque chose,
s'il n'y a rien près de chez vous, démarrez quelque chose.
AG : Démarrez.
MB : Ces conversations que nous avons,
ayez ces conversations avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Et au lieu de laisser cela être une conversation,
décidez de démarrer quelque chose.
OT : C'est vrai.
MB : C'est ce que vous avez fait,
démarré quelque chose, regardez le résultat.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ajourd'hui.
OT : Merci.
(Applaudissements)